it's become embarrassing and i know elon
just bought us uh he's the largest
shareholder in twitter tell us about
that about 11. this is big news
because elon musk what happened to the
tunnel he was building between what
happened to the tunnels has he given up
on the tunnels remember when i was on
rogan and we were talking about these
magical tunnels that elon musk why don't
you build a tunnel under austin to help
the traffic except the tunnel doesn't
you go underground and you never come
above ground the tunnel just leads and
it just drops you
into some like hole in the ground that
you can never come out of how about that
that'd be a great tunnel but i guess
we've given up on the tunnel the
ambitious tunnel system that was going
to get rid of traffic um and there's the
mars expedition but now he's buying
twitter which i'm for
i like the idea that he wants free
speech back on twitter but i think the
better idea is to just shut twitter the
[ __ ] down
that's everybody's real tank that really
thinks about it the best thing to do
would be to stop trying to make
meaningful arguments in 140 characters
or less
get the [ __ ] off it and move to one hyde
park in knightsbridge
and if you can't do that kill yourself
because there's nothing else to do maybe
pollock's peak in hong kong
perhaps but the language barrier is
something it's not nothing over there
but that is also i guess and there's
smog
but i mean so what's he doing tell
everyone what elon musk is doing on
twitter elon musk bought ten percent how
much of twitter did he buy you bought
nine percent of twitter which
how many shares is that benjamin let's
see because he made quite a quite some
cash on you yes and some of the people
at twitter are mad they're like elon
made me money but i still don't like him
it's 3 billion and then it surged by 26
in response to the news the stock well
lovely and now what's he doing he's
trying to get an edit button
and he's trying you know he's got some
concerns
about the
draconian uh policies we're seeing on a
lot of these tech sites good for him
yeah he wants to open source the
algorithm
uh what does that mean speak english uh
the choice of which algorithm to use or
not should be open to everyone
interesting so you could go on what like
a hate timeline you go i want to go on a
hate timeline today you could curate
whatever you wanted you could curate
whatever you want so it's just not only
twitter feeding it you can feed yourself
you can go i want to go on a timeline of
just celebrities and shootings
i want kardashians and school shootings
today that's my mood
i want to oscillate between meaningless
celebrity gossip and the bodies of dead
children
you can pick and choose you can curate
your timeline i want a little queuing on
today
i want a little q a on today and i like
some motivational uh
speaking
i want some bitcoin and q
i want a little q and a little coin
on the timeline today that's what my
timeline is it's just bitcoin
trans people
ever and and uh q anon related
activities that is my entire twitter
timeline it's bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
trans trans trans